she speaks five languages fluently
plus r so six languages right um she
moved to the united states three years
ago from berlin
and even though she lives in miami she
is a passionate rock climber
so everyone please welcome laura
hello everyone hi jared how are you
doing
i your welcome news is coming up very
slowly i apologize about that
all right well enjoy your talk i'm sure
he'll be excellent about the music
all right hello everyone um i hope
you're doing well i
as jared said i wish i would have joined
you in new york
today i'm joining from miami they asked
me already if i'm in a dungeon i'm not
uh but even more happy to join you here
today as you see from the title um i'm
going to be talking a little bit from my
experience of visa and my team
about how we use data and models to
work with customer engagement so it's
not a very technical
um presentation as the others but we
thought it will
give you some insight as how um
r is having more impact and generally
data
in the financial and payments um
i was just having that that talk report
uh
with jared and the organizers how and
the
our studio and r has been implemented
more and more and more
and i'm going to talk about that um in a
little bit
uh but first i want to start with a
personal story um
i'm sure that you guys are familiar with
casper uh is
the number one mattress company here in
the in the united states
um uh recently before the lockdown
i i decided to purchase a mattress
and i went of course online and i did a
lot of research
i went on amazon directly at casper
i actually ordered it and then regretted
my decision
turn it back um went with another
company and so on so
um even though there was a lot of
information especially in amazon with
all the reviews
it made it kind of struggling and it
made me
think how the user experience
and we we do hear it a lot of times um
has been changing from going to an
actual store and especially now and
these times um
it's not an option to going online
and having a whole different engagement
journey and and how the merchants are um
dealing with it right so based on that
and having that i don't know if you have
that had that
uh that personal experience as well it
was very frustrating at a point
so i just wanted to start with that to
keep it in mind
uh my name is laura gabriziak i'm a data
scientist manager at visa we have a
group it's called pizza consulting
analytics
and we work mainly with the latin
american
region and we're based in miami
i'm going to share some more information
towards the end and you can ask me some
questions um in the break sessions
but yes today we're going to talk about
the payments industry
and if you think a visa is a bank it's
not a bank it's just a rails
where all the payments go back and forth
just like mastercard
so we do get to see um a lot of data
purchase data and everything that the
car holders are doing with the carts
um the reason why we're talking about
that is that
the the markets are have been changing
since uh the last years and especially
since
um since march basically um
but overall we can say that consumers
and cardholders are not
as brand loyal as before where they
would say this is my card i'm gonna hold
on to it i'm gonna hold to this product
and instead they're more prone to switch
to another
brand just because and that has been
um an issue in the market from a
commercial side right that that's the
motivation
and the context so here's some stats
like 60
63 of customers they just um
go for the the brands and the benefits
which is good
we don't want uh and i think again we
are all
consumers of credit cards and cards
itself
we just want to be attached to a brand
we just want to maximize the benefits
that it comes along
um and then 50 of millennials there's
another topic about the new generations
that are populating the
the market and how they deal with brands
and with the products
and they will just 50 would just say
this again are studies where they say
oh i want to try another brand just
because just to test it out
um based on fomo we don't know
just to to have as much information as
possible
and then at the other side if you think
uh of the impact
that that means unlike me with the
mattress when i could
uh order it online but it didn't
actually got the product
um in the payments industry and you
probably have had that experience before
there's a lot of creation of cards um
there's like 5.5 billion
in latin america of cards that are sent
and pre-pre-ordered
that's insane so we don't know how many
of those cards are actually
activated and used and it's just
wasteful and
we can do better right think about it 66
million of accounts were open
and 64 million were closed so it's a
very dynamic
very changing market which gave us of
course the motivation
of how can we use that data i'm going to
show you a little bit more
of what data we have to be adaptive
and to be agile another fact is also the
user experience
and the user journey we're going to talk
next a little bit
they say and probably if you remember
before like that when we were able to
travel
uh remember going vacation and taking
your credit card and then the
transaction will be declined so that has
an effect
of you very likely uh not using that
card anymore
and that means that it's not top of
wallet so the moment you stop using that
card
uh your bank is not making revenue we're
not making revenue
and that is also a motivation
to to do better and to recognize and get
to know
our customers better now in latin
america
is a very specific market it's very hard
right now
to have solutions there just one
solution for
everything you probably know that um and
we're trying more and more to get uh
card holders and consumers to
um use more digital payment methods
to use more their phone things that we
we take for granted in europe
and asia or here in north america
is not given in latin america where they
have a 35
of um market penetration and um
that has been an issue especially now we
also want to encourage
um card holders to use more cards um
and also acquiring new clients
especially if they're not used to it i
was just thinking
how in the last uh four months many car
holders have been doing
their first digital payments for the
first time out of necessity
so yeah that is the whole motivation of
this talk
why it's important to be dynamic and to
think of the engagement of the client
in the payment industry um i'm going to
focus mainly
in one talking about what is a user
journey how we implement it inside an
analytics team how do we interact with
for example the innovation center
to balance each other and the second
point is to show you
some solutions we don't have that much
time today uh
but just one pilot a project that was
done in brazil
uh where think about it's like 200
million card holders
um yes to show you that
so let's start with user journeys user
journeys is the methodology used in
ux user experience design as they call
it
and it's more for a qualitative research
method than a quantitative one
so if you think about solving a problem
this will be a more in-depth
um study it's not a survey it's
basically
sometimes based on observations um i've
seen
studies where they use log files so you
can actually quantify that
but basically what you want to do is
mapping the steps or the processes
that your end user is following until he
uses or while he's using
your product or service right um
so think about a credit card and the
good thing is that many of you are
familiar with it
um for us it means we first acquire our
clients
then we engage and then we retain him
right it's very high level
first you don't have the the card so we
have to acquire you we have to get the
new client
then we have to make sure that it's
engaged that it uses it because
otherwise how many cards do you have
right and how many
do you actually use they say in an
average
a car holder has um up in average
six cars i think it's in the u.s and
they use two active parts
and that's the one that you have in your
amazon uh spotify we call that a cardone
file
and those are the the ones that uh they
use the most because of very often they
they are very lazy they don't want to
switch the card
so that's part of the user journey and
that is going to have an impact on your
product and the data that we're tracking
as well
so more into depth once we look into the
acquisition engagement and retention
uh there is a step of awareness and
again this is very high level
uh awareness but there's cross-sell
where you get all those emails
and mail from different companies with
all those five billion cards that are
not necessary
um we might also want to re-engage with
a
client with a card holder that has
stopped using
the card um and then overall gain some
interest recently there was a campaign
from a visa card
and starbucks i don't know if you were
familiar with it but those are the
campaigns
that um the public is then aware right
there's also cobram cards where you say
um
there was one with uh uber and visa as
well where you get
cash back and points um and
those will be the part of acquiring the
clients after that it's just
seeing the transactional data
and we can actually define your purchase
behavior
we call it purchase dna
and your digital dna so right now we're
looking often
to increase that engagement in the
public space
where are the car holders um
spending in the digital realm right
yes we we talked enough about the user
journey
i just wanted before that to go into the
projects that worked
in vca and uh the data that we use is
called visa net
before the lockdown we used to say that
we had 65 000 transactions per second
overall we have 50 47 million merchants
that we deal with
in the brazil market it's four million
merchants that have to be cleaned that
has to be
forced um and
it has had an impact after covet
but still there has this stock
of course um
so the first solution that i want to
share with you is called the spend
enhancement solution
basically we work a lot
once we have that the data we work
with a lot of segmentation models so we
were able to
map all those profiles for the cards and
the merchant category codes
and also we work with data from experian
which is a credit
bureau in order to have some
predictions and recommendations that we
then issue
so you're probably familiar with samsung
payne back then
we use a pilot that's called this is
me where the car holders actually shared
also their
geographic location and
putting all this together uh we were
able to
to have a whole campaign so the
variables that we used were the purchase
frequency
um we looked into the behavior of
segments so you can
track your trend from the last three and
six months um the buying moment
when are you purchasing are you
purchasing during the weekend are you
purchasing
during the week those are also things
that we track and of course the
ticket size product there's there's many
many variables
um overall we were able to send
relevant campaigns that actually had an
impact of
50 times say 50 times you're more likely
to react and actually purchase
from those campaigns and
we we launched that last year in brazil
brazil has
200 million cards i think they have
84 percent active parts um
in credit and debit um
and it was very successful using
geolocation
um we worked together we with uh 300
stores and it even increased by
24 percent by fourth the use of cashback
which was for especially the market of
latin america
they're not very educated into financial
products
so there was a huge impact
now what i was mentioning before
working with r and r studio
has helped us a lot to
be more agile and write actually our own
libraries
and instead of having a huge product
we will have many solutions that are
aligned with the steps
of the user journey
is a transition and that might be
interesting for the whole community and
this is what we're here to share
how banks and the payment industry is
also moving
from more regulated sas into our python
and and open source tools
so right now we have four main clusters
of solutions that we offer to our
clients we have the consumer engagement
monitoring program
um a consumer spend enhancer which is
the one that i presented today
we also work um with contextual
marketing
which is very aligned uh to the
previous um problem that i that i said
and it's just seeing at the the time the
spend of moment the moment of that where
you're spending
um where your geolocation and your
consumer profile we could do
a live real-time offer right
yes it also will work with revolving
enhancement and
among other solutions that if you're
working in the financial field or in the
payments industry
you can come and ask us questions
and yes so this is another use case of
products that
we develop using um our data solutions
um we create propensity models for
different
uh financial products so it's not only
which part but
um looking into credit
liquidity there's a huge problem in
latin america
where there's not enough no
financial inclusion and very often those
regulations are copying
other markets and other countries
they're not aligned with reality so
we're trying to
adapt those offers from banks to the
reality
of their societies
and create new ways of
having access to credits and to
financial products
so very often a very small
business that has no credit history it's
very hard to be
given an account or giving some some
financial inclusion
so we're looking into offers like that
and prompts like that
um right i think um
almost towards the end if if you're
interested i'm gonna be after that
in the breaking sessions um
but yes consumers are driven
by value just to to wrap up from today's
presentation
we've seen that more and more we have to
work into
the offers that we're bringing and we
have to be more agile
um one other problem that we're having
is the robustness of the models that we
constantly have to
adapt and look in the distributions that
has been a thing
and and how the interest of the
consumers is changing
so we're working on that
the second thing is that in visa we're
leveraging data
we have so much data that we can use um
to create actionable initiatives if
you're interested in that you can come
up to me
if you're we always try to look to do
some engagements with other
companies and
[Music]
that's it if you have any questions
about visa consulting analytics just
reach out
and also if you want to reach out and
present
at the our ladies miami there is
some information over there thank you
very much for the talk
so before we get to our next speaker
we're going to do a few more giveaways
this time